STEAL.
NUGGETS PLAGUED BY HIM GO
QUARTER.
>> Joh BIG MEN
TO HELP EACH OTHER.HE
FLOOR AND GOES TO
TO
DOZIER IN THE AIR.
DREW A
AUSTIN RIVERS CHECKS IN. ROOKIE.
GARLAND WILL LAUNCH FRONT OF TH.
>> John: SEXTON TO
SCORED.
NIFTY PASSGREEN.
RICOCHETTED OFF THE HANDS OF
MARKKAEERS AND APPLAUSE]. LOOSE.
JOKIC TO BARTON.
HE'S BEEN IN YEARS. AND 285 CLO.
LOVE UP AND ININ HIMSELF.
NOW NOW A TALE BYJOKIC IN SPACE.
ALLEN GOT A HAND ON ITT ZIGZAGS.
JOKIC A 3tin: THE CAVs TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF
ALLE THE LONG 2.
SEXTON DUMPS TO ALLEN AND SPINS
SCORED. THE NUGGETS
TO 38%.
THEY WERE 6th IN THE LEAGUE
SEXTON.
ON THE
AND YOU KNOCK IT DOWN D
HAVE NU.
BARTON ON MOBLEY AND GOT IT.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
MARKKANEN WANTED A FOUL.
BARTON LAYS IT IN.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].OFFENS.
CEDI OSMAN.
LOVE MAKES THEHE
MISSED.
BACK UP TOP.
DODORIVERS.
FINDS MOBLEY.
MOBL
GARLAND.
MOBLEY.17-3 RUN IN HOSTI
DRAW A FOUL AND DIDN'T GET
REBOUNDS.
RUBIO INSIDEUBIO WORKS ON GORDO.
FROM FRIENDS EN AND
CAVs STARTED. THE
TALK